بعد مسار متعثر وانقسام داخلي بين اعضائه
صوت المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا على
التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر للاعلان
الدستوري المؤقت الذي اصبح يشكل قاعده
دستوريه وخريطه طريق تجرى وفقا لها
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
تصويت لم يحظى بتوافق المجلس الاعلى
للدوله الذي وصفه اعضاء منه بالمخالف
لللائحه الداخليه له
ويرسم التعديل الدستوري نظام الحكم في
ليبيا بتشكيل سلطه تشريعيه تسمى مجلس
الامه تتكون من غرفتين وهمام مجلس النواب
ومقره في بنغازي شرق البلاد ومجلس الشيوخ
ومقره في طرابلس غرب البلاد وبتشكيل سلطه
تنفيذيه يختار رئيسها من رئيس الدوله
واللافت ان التعديل الدستوريه الثالثه عشر
لم يتضمن اي اشاره الى شروط ترشح رئيس
الدوله محيلا ذلك على الق الانتخابيه التي
من المفروض ان تصاغ بالتوافق بين لجنه
مشتركه من 12 عضوا تتشكل بالتساوي من
مجلسي النواب والاعلى للدوله وفي حال فشل
اللجنه في تحقيق هدفها تتجه الى وضع اليه
لحسم الخلاف يكون مجلس النواب حينها مجبرا
على اقرارها اذ ان مجلس الدوله يرفض ترشح
العسكريين ومزدوجي الجنسيه فيما يدعم مجلس
النواب ترشح اللواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
لرئاسه الدوله رغم حمله الجنسيه الامريكيه
اعتقد ان هذا التعديل برمته غير كافي لان
يكون قاعده دستوريه واللجنه سته زائد سته
في تقدير لين تحل هذا الاشكال الذي لم
تحلله اي لجان فيما بين المجلسين وحتى
رئيسين المجلسين عند مجتمع في جنيف هذا
الغلاف سيبقى قائم والافضل هو ان يتم
تجاوز المجلسين والذهاب الى اللجنه التي
يتحدث عنها المبعوثه بقرار هذا التعديل
الدستوري لا يتوافق مع ما اقترحه منذ ايام
المبعوث الامامي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي على مجلس الامن الدولي بتشكيل لجنه
وصفها بالتوجيهيه تتولى صياغه خريطه طريق
للانتخابات هذا العام توجه راى فيه مجلس
النواب والاعلى للدوله تجاوزا لمهامهما
اوساط سياسيه ليبيه في هذا التعديل
الدستوري ترحيلا للازمه وللخلافات بين
مجلسي النواب وال
اعلى
الى ماحقه وبالموازاه مع ذلك لم يعلن
المجتمع الدولي موقفه من خطه المبعوث
الامامي الى ليبيا ولم تبدي اطراف اقليميه
داعمه لحفتر اي حماسه لها حتى الان احمد
خليفه الجزيره طرابلس